tell me when to start talking
I can introduce this okay hi everyone
um all right we are going to be talking
about a new capability
for making
well trees that represent the structure
of code in Morphin language
so Tom why don't you take it away and
show us the create data yeah fine so the
specific thing is a data structure
wrapping of the code parser that
Brenton's been working on and is used as
the basis for lots of you know tools
that's an exciting thing right and we
believe that a data structure wrapping
would be a useful thing so this is all
Proto code not much I mean there's
there's an implementation but not of
this and I think it would be useful to
nail down some specific names so let's
just understand this is the thing that
one would use both uh you know the front
end will parse notebooks into this is
that is that a fair assessment and when
we're doing code assistance we're
parsing inputs into this and when one's
manipulating code in general this is
what one is likely that you know one can
make it into an extra struct you know
okay one can manipulate code at the
standard top level where things will
evaluate whenever they can one can turn
the code into an extra struct in which
case it's a structurally identical to
the final uh you know to an expression
but it isn't but the evaluator won't get
its fingers on it and this
is a representation of the original
source for the code which right now is
primarily strings and it is information
about how the thing was extracted from
the string and then what it and then
what the representation as an expression
is is that correct
yes I think those are correct with the
caveat that the without some work that's
not not massive but would need some work
the front end would interact with this
through the evaluator not not directly
so but but but it could be made to work
with with this directly
um with with some things like John can
you comment on that please
so Stephen I think what you're thinking
of is that the intention to uh connect
the same back end that's driving this to
the front end but the uh the uh you know
the the uh the
things on the front end are a little
different from what we'll see here
okay okay now meanwhile here
this would be the thing that
you know two string could have a version
that goes to one of these is that
correct I'm sorry to expression that the
from string something that goes from a
string could go to one of these rather
than going to yes it could do it it
certainly could do yes what you're
showing in that first example there yeah
yeah there's different sources of inputs
so I mean that's very different from
what we usually do usually in building a
data structure the step of actually
building it from The Source material
that you give is Trivial here that step
is not so trivial and it could fail it
could have a syntax error right well I
could do I could make a linked list and
give a sort of massive you know a
billion a list of a billion things no no
no no I understand that the translation
is straightforward
conceptually yes yes
you're correct yes yes right and it
could in particular have a syntax error
well this can handle this swallows
syntax errors so it doesn't so there's a
representation of a thing with a syntax
error in the code parse is that correct
yes yes okay that's that's correct yes
so so right now this is working from
strings only not from boxes is that
correct
um I think no I think this can work with
boxes as well yes no it can work with
boxes these there's underlying
implementation oh I see one there the
third element the third example there
cool yes okay you'll take boxes and then
then it would be able to do things all
right let's start seeing it I think I
understand the framing let's see the
point so there are these three different
um just run the first one there no no no
I I said I can't run things you see this
is like read-only so it was and so show
me what the heck is the potential output
well the potential output would be like
a data structure there'd be a summary
what is it like what is the data
structure what's in the data structure
what do you see when it comes back no I
understand what you see it you see a
summary box I'm asking what is the
structure of the data structure you what
what does it contain yes that's what I'm
asking right fine so so it contains the
tree of the thing that that you've
you've been getting but it's a annotated
tree isn't it yes absolutely now can I
just share one more thing and then I
could show some concrete you know some
specific examples so there are
these three different forms
Each of which is useful for different
types of analysis of of the file so this
is kind of this one here and we we could
change these these names if we didn't
like but this is the so this is the raw
material from the source so this is kind
of like the lowest level type of type of
thing then there's another version of
this which is similar to that but it's
stripped it's white spaces and comments
and then there's a thing here that's
like the actual Expressions I get it but
it's in a structured form with all of
these contain Source
um you know sort of attributions so in
in a file that's like line and yeah I
get it I get it I don't think this line
is right okay so so because I think
what's what you're doing here to think
is wrong is to stuff in to create data
structure what is essentially a you know
a sort of two parts
you know thing okay there are multiple
things I'm not you know at this point
operation but what I think should be
done is this needs to be don't don't
pretend that this is creating a data
structure I mean it is creating a data
structure but it is really doing a piece
of pausing here and there are different
levels of parse tree that you can get
out and I think that should be a
separate function but I want to see you
know for example if you take the the
code pass tree and turn it into a tree
object where does that happen
well
um so that would be a function so
right so first of all it it's going to
have things that are sort of useful and
special wait why don't I just whiz
through things quite quickly because
some of these things are useful for okay
you know code parsing and some of them
right so here's here's the thing you
might want to do is you've got the data
structure and you want to check that
it's about you know valid syntax and you
might want to get a list of the subtrees
that have errors so obviously understand
so that's a bit different from from a
regular tree that doesn't have things
wait a second wait a second wait a
second wait a second a regular tree
could have you know you could just be
doing analysis of a regular tree to get
these pieces out
or you could have a structure that has
nothing to do with the regular tree
structure and every so often it drips
out an actual tree which is it
I think it's I think as I understand it
it's the second so okay but can we see
something which is a representation of
the actual structure that's underneath
here here's kind of like the sort of
full form of this so this would be
something like the
um you know this is the expression
version so this is what would be put
into the
um um you know you you would reach this
so you would do you know in this you
would do create data structure
you know with
you do it it could code pass data
structure you would give it this input
okay my question is this
this thing that you have here right
is its own custom structure so we've got
right now yes in the system we've got
several different things running around
okay right we've got uh let's enumerate
them okay we've got the tree data
structure is Ian here to represent that
yes
yeah okay all right we've got trees okay
we've got
um
the uh text element
structure used by text structure right
right
foreign
we've got Chris Cooley's the output of
his code structure function which I
don't remember exactly what it looks
like yeah code element and code element
token
okay
um
and what other what other things do we
have what other
XML element notebook okay fine okay
expression
well and isn't there what is this um so
for for context isn't there already
something in the code parser packlet
that's like a top level version of this
I mean like there's no serialization you
have here that's that's this yes okay so
it's just this is the most inexpensive
and and limiting you see well okay so
actually that was gonna be the other
question I was gonna ask earlier you
know just a very naive question which is
one what is the the value of having this
in a data structure and two what is the
value in having this visibly as a data
structure as opposed to just being a
totally you know generic thing where you
just run code concrete parse but then
secretly on the inside there's a data
structure hiding there
well what does code concrete pass return
well and you've got to imagine this is
like figure out the name you know
you know two thousand line file
here's the point here's the point take
trees Ian's trees okay
underneath they're using data structure
but at the top level what you see is
this nice thing called tree that has
lots of functions associated with it
it's even that's actually not correct so
tree manipulates tree expressions
directly
what a treat
like the like the full form that you see
of tree that's that's what we're
manipulating we make it Atomic so that
you know only the trees code is able to
to break things apart like that but
we're just manipulating the actual
expression
okay right and my understanding is that
the compiled stuff that that was there
just worked by taking that expression
serializing it into a data structure
doing an operation and then
deserializing it back to an expression
or well and it's not compiled now or
what's happened there
so and it's a written okay I inherited
the project it was completely
implemented in top level then we were
using the tree data structure from the
compiler and and the functions directly
worked on the data structure yep right
then in 12 3 we released tree and the
way that worked was whenever we needed
to do operations we did like Christopher
said and we serialized or deserialized
it into a data structure did the
operations and then re-serialized the
result back okay
um
then in 13 1 we
we added a new algorithm for doing depth
first traversals and also extended tree
to have associations and so at that time
we took out the serialization and
deserialization into data structures so
so I understand I thought tree was a
success story for the use of the
compiler is that not correct
seems nice it's not really using the
compiler in its current form the goal
was to eventually have everything be
completely compiled but that's
not been tackled yet
right and honestly I think that it seems
like given a serialization problems it
seems like the way to do it would be to
do something much more analogous to what
people do in like kernel C code which is
that it you just have uh you know you
you just have compiled operations but
they're operating on the actual tree
expression as opposed to having to
convert it to a uh
yeah okay
all right
that would be like so much struck
wrapping so but yeah Oral B I mean in
the you know this none of this release I
mean like the list expression expression
based type thing I think that would be
the way to do it
all right so let's go back here I mean
right now with text structure for
example we've not been successful I mean
that there aren't functions that operate
on text structure particularly to my
knowledge
with XML so Ian you are redoing the XML
stuff right well this is why we're
adding an expression tree converters for
all of these things like text element
and XML element
the idea is at the first approximation
that you would convert these things into
a tree do tree operations and then
convert them back
okay but but this thing here is not
interconvertible that way this this code
pass is somehow not like that
so in the Prototype build you you can
feed this container node object into
expression tree
and it turns it into a your kind
yes can you show that Tom no I I can't
but did someone else have Ian do you
know how to do that
um yeah let me make sure it works on my
machine real quick
what okay okay so so okay so what you've
invented here is a whole other Syntax
for container nodes and Etc et cetera
Etc right
yes that's that's kind of the idea yes
right so that's what we have to focus on
yes this isn't just an appendix right we
haven't implemented much of what the
appendix is just to show some sort of I
know but this is the main event design
wise right but for context though is
there an existing although maybe it only
exists in some packlet that hasn't
really been seriously cleaned up but
like you know is there an existing
interface for manipulating container
nodes the top level ones foreign
well yeah so I mean I wasn't thinking
that this was really the main event so
with this data structure stuff if you're
working with Expressions at this point
then yeah there is no point to having
the data structure because you know
you're working with these Expressions we
haven't really touched on the advantages
of just having a data structure that you
work with yet and this what's on screen
this is oh this has existed for years
now
um
this that hasn't been exposed to users
correct but I mean I I mean we were
planning on talking about the data
structure more where you don't even see
these things
um because of the the efficiencies that
are afforded by using the data structure
which I mean we can we haven't gone into
yet but
um
there are operations that are not
possible
with expressions
that if you turn everything into an
expression
sometimes that that limits the
expressibility of what you can do
sometimes and so just the example that I
want to I just go to is you have a tree
but then you want to you know talk about
its parent it's like well you know you
can't
you can't you know Expressions
the flow of what we're doing here is you
have a certain underlying infrastructure
that you've built for dealing with code
pausing okay
what we are trying to do is make a user
exposed version of that
and you know one approach would be go
and try and document all of the details
of of what's here where instead what
we're I think saying is Let's Make a
data structure based thing that we can
document and that is useful to people it
will underneath be using things like
this but those are not things we will
document at this time is that is that
the correct flow or not
well I think you might extract parts of
these you you might want to extract
parts of these when you've navigated
down you might want to get yeah then
they have to be fully documented yeah
fine no I I absolutely in a sense this
is the data that's that's stored at
various parts of the world okay but then
then I don't understand why aren't we
just share on my screen I'm ready wow
I I mean I I only brought up the
customer at the top level thing because
I'm just go ahead
if there's already a design that's sort
of like you know or if there's sort of a
tentative design for this whole
interface that doesn't use data
structures but it's just the one that
that Brenton has been using it might be
worth looking at that if we're you know
so we don't know I agree make a whole
new design yeah we don't need to make I
mean look if we're going to okay here's
the thing if we can do this purely at
the data structure level and freshen the
design there so be it what are you doing
could you make it yeah okay thank you
the
um
you know what we don't want is to say
well we got this data structure layer
but then when you do anything real you
drop down to an undocumented previous
layer that won't work
if you never uh if people do not drop
down as much as they can yeah but if you
ever drop down to this level no I think
you need to know something about what's
there at the data level yeah so yeah if
you ever drop down to that level then
that level has to be designed yeah
obviously yes right yes but then okay
fine all right go ahead but in this
meeting since the title of the meeting
was data structure this is the tape you
know we have to decide whether it's not
necessary to have it right okay let's
let's see what Ian has here
in right so so this is code concrete
parse returning uh container node with
all of the species
so this is the tree yeah
and this is the data stored at each node
okay
so I understand tree expression uh
I'm confused can you scroll up please
expression tree of that thing comma code
so code is is your
code word for take a Brenton
code thing and turn it into a I I'm I'm
confused here tell me
a code structure for what's returned by
code parse which is the container node
object correct
yes
okay
and you're turning that into what there
this is a tree
which if I were to if I were to go tree
expression of that what would I get
so with the second argument you get the
original no no no I don't want the
second argument I want the default of
tree expression there
okay
so in other words do I then get
I'm confused do I in fact get the powers
I'm totally confused here
I kept what the heck
I mean it's so by default free
expression uses the data as the head and
the children is the arguments
okay I'm sorry I'm confused here let's
go back again to what what's going on
here what we've got from Brenton is
representations of the pars with
different levels of tagging correct
three levels of tagging am I correct yes
okay
now first question is
is the object that is produced there
structurally a tree forget about whether
it's a tree
a tree tree in the Ian sense is it
structurally a tree
or does it have additional tagging that
makes it not structurally a tree in our
sense of tree
it's it's a tree that that's true isn't
it Brenton it is a tree yeah yeah yes
but does it have additional tagging so a
tree for us has a payload of every node
and subtrees at every node
so everything you're doing so if I look
at this container node object and so on
this is
how would you represent that and maybe
this is what you're doing here as a tree
with payloads and subtrees at every node
do you understand my question that's
what this is doing like here here is
showing it without the labels
like all the extra tagging I'm just
dumping all of that into a list and
using that as the data
um
but that's not very nice I mean you know
Brenton has a perfectly nice structure
there that has I'm confused
okay this
there is a tree structure that
corresponds to the structure of the
expression itself of the poorest
expression
yeah
and there is a I'm
right well that's like it's the same
issue with text element XL XML element
like the underlying expression is itself
a tree
but if you
work with that's what I'm saying that's
why I'm saying I don't think it is right
I think that these things which are
essentially decorated annotated trees
are not quite trees in your sense
do you see what I'm saying
there's some additional structure there
which is standardized structure which is
things like where the source thing is
and so on
isn't that just data that's stored at
the nodes yes but the but okay but maybe
there needs to be a standardized format
for that data because just putting it
all on a freaking list it's not doing
anybody any good
right that list is silly
am I making sense
what you're doing is you're taking a
structured object that Brenton has you
just randomly crushing it into a list
it could be an association the data part
and the children part
we've got one slot to put data in I know
that I know that that's why I'm saying
to you
I don't think these things that Brenton
is making or that XML is making are
quite the same trees as what you have
supported well no I think the point is
is that they they okay they're not
actually topologically different it's
just a question about whether you have
extra structure in the data in that case
the data is just a list if the data were
an association and it had and you had a
nice label I don't know what the
function's called you know vertex label
function or something like that then you
know we would not be complaining we
would not be happy I know I know I know
I know that's what's happening up here
is there's a there's a label function
yeah okay but fine but the point it is
still these are still trees it's just
that they're made I understand that so
what I think it may be needed is a
standardized format for the nodes
that isn't just I mean and please the
thing that you're doing there of just
putting the random things that Brenton
has in a list this is just going to end
very badly
because in difference but to be clear
you're contrasting that with just
putting the random things in an
association for example yes or some or
some standardized structure that we
Define that is yet a different thing
more like text element that is a you
know a known structured object that
represents an annotated
you know tree element do you see what
I'm saying
yeah I'm just saying this is not a
fundamental complaint this is just kind
of a complaint about you know like this
is not a problem with using trees no
it's not a problem
yeah it's a problem that I claim that
there is something maybe it should be
called you know annotated Vertex or
something I don't know what it should be
called right something which is a
standardized version of how to do
something which has both a structural
meaning and annotation does that make
sense
Ian you understand what I'm saying but
isn't that like data and metadata
just different names yes yes yes I think
this is a bit like encoding this code
second argument is acting as an encoding
and so it's important that we remember
which encoding we used so that we can
undo it
yes but I mean so returning something
where the elements are just lists of
random things like container node is a
very bad idea
right because then we didn't we didn't
store anything we just splattered it all
over the place with random little pieces
of its innards am I making sense
right Ian do you understand what I'm
saying so I'm saying we don't want to do
this it's like so right now text element
and XML element represent trees and this
is like
changing it so that you use tree to
represent tree but now you want some
symbolic representation of the payload
that is correct yes you cannot just
splatter the payload into pieces of a
list
okay so I don't know what we're planning
to do with XML element
but I think you know it's the same thing
so but don't do it
don't do it this way don't do it that
way
okay bad idea
so but instead let's invent something
which represents in a structured way an
annotated node am I making sense
yeah like like vertex sanitations in the
graph but for trees perhaps yes
perhaps using annotation I'm not sure
but or or really what it's like is it's
just that the vertices instead of being
you know
instead of being what what you display
the vertices the vertex is some big
object
yes
um
okay so someone's asking on live stream
how is this different from graphic
visualization full form the main point
is that this has tagging information
about how the parse actually operated
and it can deal with pauses which are
not uh not even
correct pauses like if you remove the C
there
right that's a that's an actual you know
there's no full form representation of
that because it isn't a parishable thing
there's a representation of the syntax
tree
uh
what okay what happened there was a star
star sorry I didn't see that could you
do that again please non-commutative I
mean
show it to me again
okay fine
okay and put a third star there
foreign
so this is this is what the wow weird
that's a weird parse
huh weird parse I'm surprised about that
parse
what happens it's all about precedences
do we think okay I mean you know that's
a partial parse anyway but what what
happens if you just give a parse that is
obviously just do this can you do it
again at the top there
um something's just obviously wrong like
plus you know plus just a massive
brackets and pluses and parentheses
what the heck is group Square
the name for match fix operators just I
mean we can have a I mean don't wasn't
not prepared for design review right now
of of of everything but it's you know
group list group Square group paren
group ceiling I mean you know ceiling
and floor and and everything that can be
match fix
so these are the non-terminal symbols in
the in the grammar is that correct
yeah
I mean so you've got names okay well we
don't have a grammar but to be clear but
yes they would be if we had one yes
okay so wait a minute so we've got a
whole class of things here which are
the
named elements
in of which your things like infix node
is one exposure of one piece of that big
structure that is the different uh sort
of structural elements of a parse in the
language is that correct so how many so
do we have like 50 of these kinds of
things that represent
yeah I mean it's it's it's prefix
post-fix you know binary infix uh
ternary you know that's different group
nodes
um the interesting thing is with
integrals because it's actually you know
we have integral syntax in the language
and it's actually a binary operator but
the operator is prefixing the two
operands and so I have you know you make
up a name prefix binary operator
um hard to come by in the literature for
good names for things but um so I don't
know 10 10 ish whatever yeah okay fine
so it's okay so this is another thing
that has to be designed right is is this
okay so you've got this essentially
uh
and obviously I forgot uh call you know
function calls and things or two yeah
right so let me understand this so these
are
in this is kind of standardized names
for tree nodes
that have certain
syntactic you know uh that correspond to
certain syntactic kinds of constructs
right is that right yeah I mean that
that's all these are
okay
so and then for each of those syntactic
constructs you also
have at your different levels in your
concrete divide and so on thing
at each level
you also have various kinds of tagging
like what were the uh you know
characters and the source that
corresponded to this and so on
that mapped onto this is that correct
yeah
um that's what source is we see it here
with the convention for line and column
but there could be other conventions
that's what those that's what all that
source is
um and you know and there there could be
in theory more metadata but I've just
you know there's not anything more
interesting to add on so far but
um crucially when you're abstract you
know when you're talking about abstract
syntax
um there's no Source there is not Source
information Associated when you do yeah
if you go back and take out the concrete
again just to show
um you know various
um things do not have Source like the
symbol the power symbol doesn't have a
source in that input because you know it
it didn't appear there so
um sometimes sometimes they're there and
sometimes they're not yeah I understand
if they're if they're synthesized so
um there could be a thing you know I
could I could say source source rule
synthesized or something like that too
if I wanted to be complete about it but
um but yeah
okay all right I understand so
okay so let's go back again
the purpose of all of this is to have a
standardized representation of the parse
tree
that is manipulable
and
where for example let's say we have
pastry pastry and we know that there was
a runtime error somewhere
and then we want to indicate that in the
parse tree how would we do that
how would we yeah so I mean there are
here errors here so instead to make it
simpler just just do a plus
in that
it's a bit complicated that yeah there
we go
and so in there you can see error um
yeah error node so analogous to Leaf you
know all of these names are up for
debate but again not prepared in this
meeting for talking about this we were
prepared for data structure stuff but
this is the existing Tech
um error node representing you know
obviously expected operand for that but
you could have other errors but this is
a syntax level error so my question is
this you know one of the things we want
to use this for
or maybe I'm confused I mean in you know
in the case where it's syntactically
correct but at run time a runtime error
is generated
and
you know we want to store information
even on something like the stack about
what
part of the initial source
you know was being run when the error
occurred yeah which includes right so
that's that's a a you know very
reasonable thing to want to do so what
we would do then is make make it a plus
b for example and it's
blue
actually sorry make it make a function
definition like f bracket colon equals F
Open Bracket Colony yeah colon equals x
right brilliant
right let's do that so
we would want to maybe somewhere with
the down Value store that name of the
file or the Box ID or and the position
in that file or the input string I mean
the String's not so interesting but
we we could then go and store that
somehow in in a way that has to be
determined
um where where that Source came from
right
can I say one other thing another virtue
of the data structure interface is it's
quite efficient and so we could and and
the data structures are also quite
integrated into the kernel so we could
actually switch getting needs to call
the data structure parser rather than
the existing kernel parser and then we
would get this information flowing into
it just okay so let me understand what
you're suggesting so you're saying in
down values
somehow
that we would store
this the data structurized version
of
this Source information
yes I think so yes yes I think yes
that's correct we would score the Source
information that had been generated by
the pars so
um
we could do that so okay there's one
thing in the in the down values is just
the straight code this is the code to
run yes
as well right okay but then there's also
this is The annotation of source
information
from from you know the raw code that is
you know so we might have two pieces we
might have in down values we might have
you know I mean I mean right now what we
have is the left hand side and the right
hand side
and you're saying there's a there's an
additional piece which is the um the
kind of source provenance of that down
value element right so that's a very
coarse-grained notion of of
um of of source information but it would
be useful for messages and things like
that I mean you could you could know
what notebook it came from you could
know what well obviously like I mean but
things like that but I mean okay all
right so fine so we're talking about
storing a thing if we had more
fine-grained information we we could
know what you know what sub part of the
expression could be stored so we were
talking about the compiler errors we
could go and mark up the coloring in the
source notebook you see if yes okay
there's quite a bit of plumbing and
scenery to reach that Tom do we want to
go back to your agenda here sure of
course I mean I I want to make sure we
cover all this right
right fine Tom can you share again
please oh yeah hang on didn't talk [ __ ]
oh yeah hang on there we go right I'm
I'm sharing
okay so this is the data structure
version
um and these were some of the things
that we you know the different
parsing struck you know then then you
can pause you can get syntax errors I'm
not getting this I'm not understanding
this so far so I mean we've got this
whole Giant sub language of essentially
our
syntax tree sub language right
okay so supposing I did let me just give
a demo I want to ask a question I mean
yeah
for example in Chris Cooley's
code structure
you must have similar kinds of
constructs is that true or how did you
do that
yeah it's very similar to the text
element
um and we you know if you want the
tokens you know there's a layer of code
element tokens
um and every you know we don't
every time you you you parse C you know
it's always going to give you a source
range so it's like
uh for the the okay code element
yeah do you want to bring this up with
those contombing it up there's a wfr
entry for code structure right yeah wait
why doesn't Chris do it because he's
probably better at demoing it are you
ready to do that
yeah so it just it's very simple it just
looks like this right and you'll notice
the scores range
okay but so you have things like
function decal and yeah Etc okay so
that's your analog of what Brenton is
naming you know Brenton has names for
certain elements of our language like a
group you know a ternary group thingy or
whatever it is right and you so
everybody is having sort of named
um
has named pieces of the syntax so to
speak yeah
okay
now how analogous
is this to what Brenton is doing
Brenton can you comment on this
yeah this is the first I've seen I'm I'm
just looking
[Music]
I mean it seems very analogous I know
that's why I understand yes that's why
I'm bringing it up right
so but what seems to be the case is that
everybody has certain
you know identify it then I what should
I call them certain
tags names whatever for some tactic
pieces
and there's a question of what should
those be should those be entities in the
end should they be what what should
those be
well so I can speak a little bit to the
design which I mean I'm not I wasn't
prepared but
um everything with the design that we
were seeing what that Ian had on his
screen before with all of my my symbols
and my names and things
um efficiency was the key uh so what so
what are those things so that's being
able to dispatch quickly on the heads
and the first arguments because of the
choices that you probably want to make
you know based on you know okay but what
how are they implemented what are they
your container node that's just a symbol
right Contender node is a symbol true or
not true
yeah they're all these are all just
there's no implementation I mean we're
talking about the representation like
what's on screen now like there's no
implementation underneath this this is
just this is all symbolic
no no no I'm asking the question if you
introduce your ternary group operator or
whatever it is you know your thing
that's analogous to Chris's function
decal here right
my question is for for Chris here
function decal is what is that a string
is that a can you do like input form of
that thing or something yeah I think
it's a string
okay okay so you have certain name
strings and you have certain structural
pieces like your code element token
which is probably something analogous to
something Brenton has what is Brenton's
analog of code element token
well if it's a leaf node
is what I'm calling
okay the end points okay so fine so that
might be that your Leaf node which is
again a function for you
or a symbol for you right just like it's
a symbol here code analysis code element
token yeah symbol here okay and then it
has certain things in it like the
punctuation piece there is saying what
kind of a thing that is right so what
what Chris seems to have here is the raw
string the what kind of a thing it is
and then certain tagging information
like Source range is that is that
correct
I think that's a reasonable way to
describe it okay so you're always got I
mean there's always a three-legged
animal so to speak You're you know that
everything here is a code element token
with
the The Source text
the description of the nature of the
thing and uh annotation information is
that is that right
well for the code elements they've got
you know they've got the child elements
uh the thing it is in the source range
okay
the thing it is wait a second so okay so
if you were to represent this here in
terms of trees
your code element token is a leaf is
that correct
yeah and so I can I can just show what
it looks like you know this hasn't been
integrated into the tree project yet but
uh
like it
if you want uh let me try to find
something that's a little
yeah you can see it's kind of have a
different it has a little bit of a
different formatting
uh you know we just give you the actual
text we don't give you
you know we don't give you information
about what kind of token it is
yeah although in the case of text
element the text structure the analogous
thing text structure is is putting a
line under there and saying noun phrase
or something
uh
isn't it
I would recommend
whatever it's a method of finding this
Chris has a form of displaying that
yeah like the underlying yeah so
it kind of gave you the type of the
you know
yeah right so if you if you if you
display it in a different way you know
like Ian's talking about you can get
that information and that's called this
annotation thing
okay okay okay
all right
let's go um
so Brenton so this is literally the
first you've seen of Chris's I mean this
is from years we we have looked today
actually I think so but yeah
okay all right so Tom let's go back to
your screen if we can sure right right
fine so
like for example I don't know if you can
see this so if you did the anything
right now you're not sharing
right that will help right fine now you
can see so in this idea if you did
something like this so
syntax Q would return true and then when
you've got pause this would return so
let's say false for that you've done
false in that case syntax Q yeah
yeah let's let's say that right and then
you ask the errors you'll get a list and
these would be also data structures that
are sort of pointing inside of the thing
that represent the error nodes as as
data structures you see so
okay
um I mean maybe we don't like this this
is just an idea okay look again let's go
through it again okay
we've got sometimes just whiz through a
little bit more of this and then let's
go back and go if you want all right if
you want so sorry I mean go ahead go
ahead go ahead okay super quick right so
extract subtrees based upon position and
things and then that we we need some
sort of path mechanism to reach siblings
and parents and I think there's a tree
designed for that
um now here's some more like some sort
of cases notion but yes I understand the
confunctionality is good the design you
can unhorify it maybe so this is similar
to tree map you know that's crazy I mean
it's just crazy we're making up some
bizarre backward syntax because we're
trying to avoid having this actually
using cases and so on well thanks
absolutely correct yes if we can figure
that out
it's not think about it we have we have
five gigabyte data data files
that need to be parsed
and it it would be the definition of
insanity to bring in the expression
version of those just so you're not
understanding what I'm saying you're not
understanding what I'm saying I'm you're
not understanding what I'm saying hang
on Stephen what are you saying then
right right what I'm saying is this
syntactic form is wrong fine but but
what I'm saying is I'm not saying that
the thing on which we operate is a
traditional communal Garden uh
um you know expression right that would
also be wrong we need to have some
mechanism to use we cannot have a
backwards you know pseudo Syntax for 30
different functions here
okay
so what instead we need something in a
sense with the tree project that's
exactly what was done because there's
tree map and tree extract and tree no
you know I know but it's not but if you
don't like that it's done no no no no no
no no it's very good
because it's been specialized for trees
in a way that's but here you're doing
this backwards you know El Cheapo we're
just going to use strings in sub-value
positions okay fine so you could have
you want something like this past cases
if we if we want to do that yes
that would be fine we need to do that
it's not obvious we need to me that we
need to do that so you want this to work
okay that's why I'm pushing on the
question of is this thing really like a
tree well so the problem is tree is
still just top level expression people
worrying about implementation that's
what you're talking about right I'm
talking about the design okay I'm
talking about what is the design the
implementation will be the same as what
you have right now
has on on screen yeah we could have a
thing right we could have a function
like tree cases that that could work on
this that that okay but the the point
design wise
okay okay they're two different things
there is the largely atomic
sort of data structure based efficient
blob of stuff that represents the five
gigabytes away okay then there is the
way of representing
functions being applied to that
where the typical thing that will happen
just as it happens in trees or data or
data sets or data structures for that
well not data structures trees or data
sets for example
is you operate with a a sort of
a standard top level thing and the
return
is one of these blobs
am I making sense right and that's what
it would be here you've got a five
gigabyte blob you use some nice you know
tree cases or whatever it returns a two
gigabyte blob let's say right
it's you know blob to blob stuff and
there's some some way of resolving at
the end those blobs into uh you know
ordinary Expressions am I making sense
exactly yes
yeah yeah you may not need to you may
just be using comparisons or yeah
putting it out somewhere else okay so
what we're talking about here the goal
of this is to design something that is
you know a usable understandable thing
and we're not designing something that
is going to have you know all kinds of
weird sub-value jokes right right fine
so that's how it gets implemented
internally so be it but that's not what
the top level design is
right
okay what do you want to show what else
do you want to show right fine I mean
these are just some of the things you
know we want sort of some way of
navigating and updating so that's kind
of work hard whatever okay do it this
way but open that up again okay and
let's do a little exercise what should
this be
well you could have like I put up there
you could have tree map
okay so that's really the question could
we put
you know could we overload Ian's tree
star functions to operate on these
you know on these kinds of parse trees
or do we need a whole new family of
parse map and so on there'll be
functions that don't exist in the tree
world oh there is a tree cases there may
be functions that don't exist well but
maybe they could exist or should exist
but they could exist yeah right so
that's the question I mean are they
functions that are essentially
structural functions that could be
applied to trees you just don't
typically care for trees that aren't
parse trees or are they things that
depend on the fact that it is a parse
tree
nothing that I I believe nothing we're
talking about
depends on it being a parse tree like
working
right there might be one that is a bit
like okay fine one at the end yes yeah
what you're saying is is correct I I
suspect you know this would be
you know like par
um how do you get the data from from a
tree you know tree data tree data Ian
should say but my vote would be for
overloading the the tree functions yeah
yeah
I I think that's kind of the goal is
okay for the map to be able to work on
okay let me know
the the one thing that's needed here is
a standardized uh data payload for a
parse tree right the thing that you had
before where you splattered it into that
list wasn't going to work
am I making sense
yeah
okay so what's needed is the thing that
happens here will look like a tree walk
and talk like a tree it's one special
feature is that it's data payloads will
have a different form
as maybe a parse element or something
and you know that is directly analogous
to Chris's
uh you know code out what was it code
what are you calling it element
no but but then the inner thing the
token piece the little element token
okay fine
so I I believe that what's there is
directly analogous to that what what
needs to be there it's directly
analogous I don't know whether you need
two of those things you might need two
two such things to be the
the payload elements in the tree
am I making sense
is this making sense Ian Brenton this
has to make sense to Ian to treat people
sorry
um yeah you you want some kind of
explain this data and metadata
yeah I want to standardized and I
suggest that Chris may have already
developed this
and and it seems to have developed
something incredibly analogous to what
Brenton has developed well yeah I mean
like so the the payloads and trees could
be the actual Leaf nodes for example you
know that that already that were already
being shown too
which which in your situation are what
what are your Leaf nodes like well yeah
I mean you know the order of the first
two arguments is are just reversed from
Chris's stuff
um you know what it is and then the the
string version you know the the payload
so uh and then and then Source
information so
um it looked like uh extremely analogous
yeah okay fine fine okay so then then
that's what we need we need a name thing
that is the the uh I mean and and that
particular type of name thing I could
imagine being used for text elements as
well
um sorry I have a comment so one of the
ideas in this second argument of tree
expression on expression three was that
the same three could be reconstructed in
different ways
my interpretation of your idea is that
when we go from the expression to the
tree we insert in the data the encoding
that was used the the the type of
expression where it came from
which will help in reconstructing of
course but will prevent reinterpretation
sorry sorry I lost something could you
say that again yeah so this is one of
these balances questions
of encapsulation versus having
information outside I would say so so
the our idea was that the same tray
could be reconstructed in different ways
like do you have an association do you
want to see the rules or not
do you pass it as an expression or as an
association yes and so if we insert the
original type of expression in the data
of the trees then we are forcing that
the tree will be reconstructed in that
form
I am slightly confused I mean I you know
you're saying that that Brenton has
defined three levels of abstractness or
not for the pausing that's going on I'm
kind of guessing that Chris might have
had a similar thing in in uh in code
structure but maybe not
of different levels of pausing I don't
know
um maybe not because yeah okay
I mean I'm sure it's available from I
mean it uses clang I think so I'm sure
it's all available somewhere there might
be more things to do with macros there's
probably a pre thing before the macro
system runs you know it might be more
than three
with declarations and definitions and
things I mean I I would guess that there
are five levels uh off the top of my
head yes yeah we don't have Wolfram
language doesn't have declarations you
know versus versus anything else so yeah
three
three here maybe more in other languages
well but but when we have the new
package structure I don't know if
anybody's talked to Connor about that
there there may be more layers when
there's the new package structure yeah
yeah that's that's totally correct yes
there'd be a package layout as well yeah
okay which right now there is not
because with this the package format
version one you know that has always
been existed and documented
um begin and begin package those are
just functions that execute so you know
there's nothing special about how they
parse but you know yeah and Connor's you
know new you know working on the package
format V V3
um there would be yeah that are not
evaluating that need representation yeah
right
okay
so I mean we need to wrap this up for
today right there's one last thing that
is is slightly useful and that's to get
to use this tree to actually like get
the expression the same as two
expression and get do like like get the
thing and evaluate the input yep
I understand okay so look the thing we
need to do and
well yeah that probably doesn't exist
that is quite special
yeah tree expression and tree fold would
be the closest no no tree expression
isn't that getting the data that's in
there
this is like tree fold with the
evaluator being run at every at every
folding step I believe a top level
version implementation of the evaluator
yeah being applied yeah yeah
right that's what that is
okay so maybe
um
okay so let's come back here the only
thing I'm I'm unclear about and maybe
the three people can enlighten me is
exactly how do you get data how do you
get metadata how do you get both how do
you get what you know what's the what's
happening that's all been defined but
for trees that's all very nicely defined
in trees right can someone show me
well could you go back to sharing please
because we got to wrap this sure fine
right right let's not do that here could
you go back please yeah yeah okay we we
could work up much of this in terms of
the tree
let's just let's just outline again what
we're going to be looking for here okay
we're going to be looking for a
a
payload
something that is uh you know a
standardized thing in the payload that
is called something like
um you know structural elements or
something let's just say or or
you know sourced element let's call it
sourced element it's not a very good
name but but let's say it's called
sourced element
okay
um and that would be something in common
between text element code
you know the code element
and
Brenton's
thing here and and what it would contain
is as we all know it contains the Raw
Source that's why we're calling sourced
element
the raw Source the interpretation of
this thing as in it's a you know a
grouped ternary animal or whatever it is
um
you don't need to say turn right thing
animal As You Wish yep yep yep it's a
good one
um
and then uh and you know the provenance
information
no
right
yes EG sauce blah blah blah okay isn't
this just metadata
but well I mean I I want to be specific
here because because what's important
about this it is useful to say it is a
pointer back to the source
right not just oh we're going to give
some random thing and it might be point
to the source and it might be the the
thing you're saying this is required
I'm saying for a sourced element that's
what it's all about it's yeah yeah
right that's that's because it contains
the actual Source look there's two
things about the source what it was you
know brace star whatever it is and
there's where did where was that yeah
fine okay and I think largely if that's
all that Chris provides and that's all
that I provide in my Association
then it's kind of strong evidence that
that's all that we actually care about
yeah no I agree but I think that given
that those things are what you're
providing I think having standardized
sort of positions for those and not even
using you know not even potentially
having a um you know a tag name like
Source position or whatever it is just
those are the three things boom boom
yeah it's good to disambiguate between
the different versions of source because
it could be mine that's fine that's fine
yeah fine fine fine there's some but
then then there's a yet different thing
then we need some kind of symbolic
Source identifier right that could be a
file a line number whatever okay let's
do that because what we then want to be
able to do is you extract the symbolic
Source identifier and then you say show
it to me or color it or do whatever else
you want to do to it right so you're not
then you don't have additional logic
that's all just something where you
extract the symbolic thing and then you
can do stuff to it does that make sense
I think so yeah
okay so now
what we're saying is
there is a function
that turns
you know it's it's it's a parse tree
function effectively
or
I don't know what it's you know it's
like code structure and it might even be
that code structure
you know that we have that we now
finally introduce code structure into
the language with code structures
defaults being well from language
do you see what I'm saying because it
looks to me like this is really going to
be the same kind of structure as code
structure and why not allow the
possibility that code structure can
operate on C and this and that and the
other as well if they are similar enough
okay so the function is code structure
maybe maybe maybe I don't know or maybe
it's parse or or maybe it's you know
it's code I don't know yet okay fine
okay I don't know whether it's a shared
function between open language and other
languages or not okay fine right sure
okay
there's quite a bit here to work with I
think wait a minute we're not done yet
okay so so now
uh
so the thing that gets returned
by code structure code pass whatever
presumably is a tree whose only special
it might be I don't know if this is
correct a tree whose only special
feature is that its payloads are these
sourced element payloads I don't think
that's right I think it's going to need
some outer wrapper around the tree where
it says this is a code parse tree or
something am I making sense
where the innards is a tree that you
could take out and just manipulate as a
tree just like if you wanted to you
could take a tree and turn it into a
graft and manipulate it as a graph but
you would lose certain things which are
part of the you know tagging and other
other information about the tree
does that make sense
that's fine so there's no data structure
there's none of the none of that
well I don't know I mean I think this
could work using a data structure where
does the data structure go in this I
don't know maybe it doesn't need it
because tree doesn't use data structure
I thought it was
okay
okay
so now the operations on this
now you want to do things and this is
where you know because you need things
like tree cases and so on do you have
three cases in
yeah
okay fine so that's an argument for not
using Code Barse tree but just having a
negative tree well I I don't know I
don't know I mean it could be the three
cases
is some kind of thing that if you give
tree cases you ask for three cases of a
cold pastry it does three cases of the
inner tree and then just wraps the
resulting code pastry I don't know
did you get what I'm saying
yeah
I don't but let me explain it okay the
issue is
you want to use the function tree cases
to do
cases type Transformations on codebars
trees yeah okay
so the only question is if we had an
outer wrapper code Forestry
that would get gum up the works
of the naive tree cases but we could
have it be the case that tree cases
simply you know Burrows through code bar
Street does the operation on the inner
tree and then replaces it called pastry
on the outside when it comes out
it could could do that
yes I don't know if that's necessary and
it depends on whether there's metadata
that needs to be kept in the code purse
tree or whether we can treat well this
is purely an application of trees
there's no data stretching it's just
going to ride on top of the tree project
I think so fine looking like it I mean I
I don't see any reason not to do that
is there a problem with that
it's probably unusably unusable for
things like marking up down values and
things like that replacing get and needs
um sorry I'm sorry I don't understand
that no I don't understand that look I
don't understand we just went through
this okay fine great but we just went
through this okay if you need a special
thing that is your special kind of tree
that is atomic as far as you're
concerned right then have that but the
function three cases then needs to work
on that
yes yes I I that's that's what I'm
saying that that would be totally fine
so then it's a code pass tree with a
some sort of atomic
thing no
no I'm saying or it's tree with atomic
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter no code pass tree that's
fine right and the right code pass tree
there
but then the the key point is that the
functions that work on trees work on
this the same way yeah fine right
so we're not inventing a whole new you
know yeah yeah I I get that like when
you say the same way do you mean
returning trees always or do you mean
returning the same kind of thing that
was given as in I think 15 gigabyte blog
yes I think it was the same thing that
was given okay okay so what it could do
is it could have special code that's
optimized for certain things and the
other cases will fall back to converting
it to a tree expression doing the tree
thing and then going back in reverse
right and and I'm sure
we should say tree of a code purse tree
just like graph of a tree turns
everything into a graph right yeah tree
of a code purse tree could just turn it
Roar into a tree yeah if you requested
that yeah right which wouldn't be what
you would do when you're doing high
performance correct classified stuff
yeah
so I think the thing we need to
understand is when you turn it into a
tree
what you will see is these Source
elements sourced element pieces and
things like that in the tree it is a
tree except that it's its payloads are a
little bit customized
does that make sense Brenton
yeah um I mean it makes yeah I mean I'm
not sure I would be the one doing it for
trees but yeah
well it's just that's just the
conversion that's just the output after
the conversion yeah right so so one
issue with this is what happens if you
do a transformation that's valid for
trees but isn't really making a code
pass through
is that that's an error I presume what
what kind of a thing is that well
supposing you just put something that
doesn't Boop the code plus trees have
have a structure to them you know I mean
obviously it's just an error I mean yeah
glue something on
yeah I think this can work
okay I I pretty really like this design
I think anybody else want to comment on
this
John fultz if he's been
yeah I've been I've been modestly paying
attention and yeah I think the notion of
applying you know the tree functions to
you know kind of as if
um yeah yeah that that seems that seems
reasonable and then any new top level uh
three functions which are implemented in
terms of other tree functions would
would work for free anything that needs
to kind of Dig Down would need to be you
know overloaded and implemented for uh
you know for for the code for parser
stuff but uh yeah I mean the design is
reasonable okay so then let's as an
exercise we need tree element code
element and this
and it would also and also XML element
we it will be nice to see make sure that
the things we're imagining working here
with you know Brenton's statement oh you
need to be able to get parents of things
Etc et cetera et cetera you know that
all of that works in all of these cases
and that will be something for Ian yeah
fine I mean Ian's just gonna say what
the language is and then it'll be
implemented
all right anybody Christopher or anybody
else you want to comment on anything
here
no I mean I think it sounds good sounds
good
all right very nice good stuff right and
it'll be exciting to see this this come
together this is all good I mean what
we're going to need basically what what
we're saying here is that there are
string names
for these sort of components of the
parse just like
Chris had string names in code structure
you're going to have string names in
this which you've already got basically
right yeah we will have to review these
names and things of course but I know I
know I'm not thrilled with the fact that
they're strings but it's probably the
lesser of evils sure
for my Christmas stuff or my stuff what
do you say stuff your stuff well my
stuff doesn't isn't in isn't strings
though
what is it my stuff is symbols
yeah which which we're not going to need
if we have a sourced element thing
you're just going to put everything
inside sourced elements and those tags
will become strings and sourced elements
uh if you
say I mean if you want them to okay sure
well that's what we need because we
don't want a sub language of some kind
of extra symbols right where would we
put that sub language
well the language is plus and times I
mean I don't know they're they it is but
there's things like infix node and
binary node and leaf node things like
that Brenton aren't there yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
I had to add 10 new things to the list
of you know 8 000 system symbols but
okay okay
if it's as small as 10 and we can have
broad support for those things then so
be it
okay so so let me understand what is
what's an example of one of those things
um I mean yeah I mean binary node and in
fixed node if if that's what we're
talking about okay yes okay fine so what
is binary node a binary operator you
know um you know at a at B
that is a binary operator
why don't we come up with an exhaustive
list of this yeah um so this wasn't I I
didn't prepare for this yeah but hold on
hold on this could be a perfectly
reasonable
you know
something
I'm confused here because this is yet
another thing that reminds me of the Box
language and so on it's another kind of
symbolified representation
if I'm making sense you see what I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah you you are yeah
right so what's the relationship I mean
it's it's close both in purpose and you
know and function uh to the Box language
yeah and it goes back and forth you know
there are functions for going back and
forth
um you know but it you know it's not
correct
I wouldn't want to use robots for
everything you were doing though yeah no
you wouldn't it would be but but this is
an interesting thing I mean okay we've
got three levels of this now because
we've also got functions like infix
which was introduced in like version one
which is a a typesetting construct yeah
which may not be documented anymore I
think I can't remember I'm not sure I'm
not sure but but um I'm not sure
I think you have to put an F in there as
well I think there's not going to be any
oh that yeah right no who knows it may
be okay I I understand but my point is
we got it into you know we got to unify
these Concepts and I'm not actually not
objecting Brenton if it's really true
that you've only got 10 of these I think
ish yeah plus or minus two yeah yeah
yeah okay that's that's fine but you
know but but on the other hand it's very
different from the number of
of um
ah yes
right
right so so okay so you've got these are
abstract
syntactic binary operators
which of course infects isn't going to
work with more than two arguments right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay so I know I I my tendency would be
to say we probably do want to introduce
these but they need to have a correct
and understood correspondence to box
language and to this formatting language
yeah
um which I would love to do in a meeting
that I've prepared everything for Yes
sounds good all right
this this this made great progress on
this yeah that's good and um uh I look
forward to seeing the next step good
stuff
see you guys soon